le malheur de l'humanité chez d'être
trop nombreuses
1971 l'écrivain barjavel alerte sur la
surpopulation mondiale après le 19e
siècle et sa révolution industrielle
le nombre de personnes sur terre n'a
cessé de croître décennie après décennie
passant de 1,4 milliard vers 1850 à 7,7
milliards aujourd'hui
soit près de six fois plus en un siècle
et demi et voici ce que redoutait déjà
les experts dans les années 70 si cette
progression n'est pas stoppée par un
nouvel élément
nos descendants ne disposons à cette
époque que d'un mètre carré par habitant
les conséquences de la surpopulation
inquiétait aussi l'économiste italien
aurelio pétillent
en 1973 le monde a augmenté la présence
humaine d'une façon épouvantable dans
les derniers 10 ans 20 ans on est un
phare dun nouveau doublement de la
population
probablement dans 30 40 ans aurelio
pixels et le fondateur du club de rome
un groupe de réflexion international
réunissant scientifiques économistes aux
fonctionnaires et industriels préoccupé
par l'avenir de nos civilisations en
1978 leurs recommandations étaient
plutôt alarmistes
il faut construire un deuxième monde
seconde monde pour abriter les nouvelles
vagues de population si nous ne sommes
pas capables de faire ça alors je pense
que les souffrances humaines seront
presque infini les désastres bien plus
grands que ceux du passé
même inquiétude pour rené dumont en 1974
je vais vous parler ce soir du plus
grave des dangers qui menacent notre
avenir celui de la surpopulation tentes
dans le monde que en france premier
candidat écologiste à une élection
présidentielle
il faisait de la surpopulation l'un des
thèmes majeurs de sa campagne il faut
arrêter la croissance de la population
française et la proposition de la france
de 100 millions d'habitants est une
proposition à caractère criminel
elles menacent l'avenir de nos petits
enfants elles menacent l'avenir de
l'humanité
dans les années 70 les experts
estimaient que la population mondiale
atteindrait 10 milliards de personnes
d'ici à 2100 un chiffre que l'onu prédit
pour un peu plus tôt en 2050
[Musique]